in her first state of the european union
speech
commission president ursula van der lion
vowed to lead the eu to a strong
green economic recovery members
challenged the commission on the
humanitarian crisis in greece
and enforcing the rule of law
members voted to open the way for the
ratification process of the union's own
resources decision
which would allow the commission to
raise 750 billion euros on the markets
for the eu recovery plan
there have been around 2.25 million
coveted 19 cases in the eu
parliament called to harmonize the way
member states categorize
hard-hit regions to ease travel across
borders
in belarus more than 7 500 people have
been detained at demonstrations against
the results of the august election
members urged the eu to impose sanctions
including on belarusian president
lukashenko
more than 12 000 people were left
without shelter sanitation or access to
food
after a fire destroyed the maurya
migrant camp in greece
parliament discussed how to ensure that
a humanitarian disaster like this
never happens again